[Applause]
Jubilees it's been a while it got a bit
much there for a while
tambourines back however so we're ready
to get back into this no this is ten
versus one speed-dating ten gotten away
what I can't read speed-dating ten guys
were seeing them that's what I'm trying
to say she's gonna speed-date guys and
not judge by their look see if I did
this I would just try and figure out
their looks by listening to the that's
the goal right come on nice to meet you
just like Amazon huh I get that so often
he's that he's definitely out I'm Alexa
nice to meet you just like Amazon huh I
get that's like just a little pro tip
here if you're trying to date someone
new maybe save the name jokes I
guarantee you she saw them already get
that so often Alexa yeah but I make sure
I'm making me a sandwich you want well
I'm out and for that for those reasons
I'm out got it I'm just playing it's
like that thing I can bite yo Alexa
flavor this song
oh why he made the same joke as oh god
the cracked so three out of 10 made the
joke that's great you guys are comedians
applies tambourine of shame to all of
you gone alright let's get into this I'm
nervous
if I'm being honest
Aleksei day ten potential matches get it
ha ha ha ha ha I feel like I will yes
I'm pretty good about picking up
inflections of like voices and
everything and I can tell if somebody's
being honest with me or not by their
voice
what that the point is to find out if
they're ugly stop lying stop lying
thank God do really well like that got
another got another guy that's either
way too nervous or just stone out they
always find one hello what's your name
I'm ago what's your I'm Alexa nice to
meet you nice to meet you that's really
cute things oh thank you now Alexei make
me a sandwich that's a really cute name
he passes like Amazon sorry I wanted to
make that look how old are you I'm 18
how what are you I'm 23 okay it's not
wearing shoes what the hell they're not
all okay they're all night wait okay
sorry sorry how what are you I'm trying
to be okay hey what's your name is Howie
even I'm not that awkward and I can't
even speak gone cringe this is dating
tips for you guys write this down how do
you think I got marks there I went a go
look at this yo yo bro and the rest is
history
do you have any goals in the future yes
one of my biggest goals right now is to
uh reduce the amount of a hair gel in my
hair I've been trying to cut down I'm
actually a big dead
I can't someone have please help me have
enough money to buy my mom her own house
well maybe cut down on the hair gel and
you can afford it Alexa buy me hair gel
my name is Alexa oh wow that's my mom
thing
really no no oh good joke nice oh that's
my mother
alright then what's the point that is
not a joke goddamn it guys
you're letting me down here can we get
someone good in there yes I'm studying
to either be a marine biologist or a
psychologist Oh marine biologist well
what's your favorite type of body of
water then huh can you answer me that
into ten seconds where do you go I go to
Biola it's a Christian College that's
cool so you're Christian yes no I'm
Hindu Buddhist Islam of course I'm
Christmas you dumb [ __ ] of course I'm
Christmas goddammit I should not talk
down to people when I'm this stupid I'm
sorry I apologize
very much though we're just a little bit
very much so
so are you like working are you going to
school or something I'm working on
getting work yeah
and for that reason I'm out she's
unemployed okay I love all the arts so
painting photography's
you're poor is what you're saying poor
gang ain't nothing wrong with it poor
gang stuff like that how about you I I'm
actually really into airplanes
I'd say photography I do a little bit of
camera shoots and stuff like that so I
guess we have something in common there
yeah what cool so they're both
unemployed that's awesome it's good
hi Oh God my name is Tyler I'm gonna ask
you a question really quick this is
really important if we went to
Yogurtland would you put chocolate on
your yogurt or fruit because that's not
really important to me I put those okay
you're already a freak I can tell are
you alright that's kind of funny follow
what I hate those questions though
really this is so important and then
they ask something epic random what's
your favorite character in Riku morning
if you answered mr. poopy butthole
that means she likes eight
let's move on I'm awesome yeah I can
tell your voice you sound like really
energetic yeah I'm super outgoing and
everything all right who she's gonna
eliminate I'm guessing the second guy
and the Christian guy I'm gonna have to
get rid of JD because I just didn't feel
like a connection is Jamie but the one
after Caleb also just didn't really feel
like how the hell does she remember
names what the hell okay yeah yeah oh my
god I am the Prophet all right let's see
rightio date would be I don't wanna be
too cliche but long walks on the beach
but also I always wanted to go on a
ferris wheel with one beautiful girl
although I'm always going on 1500
picking taking long walks on the beach
cringe bro my ideal date I win the jodeo
championship tournament everyone loves
me I have a great day and then would
smash B place smash yes mine would be
probably driving around and Paulie end
up on the beach pretend I know about
constellations and stuff so I'm gonna
tell you straight off the bat like I
suck at planning you know like oh don't
tell girls that you have to pretend that
you like planning no guys are good at
planning they you don't say it it's our
only weakness come on okay all right so
so bear with me here I put a lot of
thought into this okay so so I'm working
on get my pilot's license I'm thinking
you and me we go we go we hop into a
little private plane at the airport
right we take it we fly up the coast of
California and you know there's little
islands off the coast right we could go
and kind of fly over to one of the
little islands obviously you're in a
photography you bring your camera get
some nice shots Wow Wow
this guy's basically offering her to be
the the camera guy boyfriend how the
hell do you sign up for that willingly
have you seen those people go into the
protest the girls are just there to be
like oh look BLM guys and then the
boyfriend is there taking the photo
he's basic saying I can be that guy but
we all know they're all in pain and
don't want to be there means with each
other because my main game is crazy so
like if you don't have good taste and
means we can't be a thing like this is
not gonna work
trust me I have an entire folder yeah
everyone has to fall there don't pretend
that you like memes okay I like me
that's my thing laughter I think
laughter is really really cool I like to
do like impressions and stuff like that
so like by Penta that's soaked oh my
gosh what is your name
that was Lemongrab from n venture time
right did I get that right what is your
name see how hard that was is it is it
Black Panther I haven't even seen it
alright let's see let me go initially I
felt kind of a connection but after that
I just kind of it kind of went away a
little bit and then whoever the third
person was and it's cuz initially he
just immediately said he was bad at
planning
yeah right right I told you I told you
like that cuz I love being creative and
all that kind of stuff just say dude I
love planning I planned for my yo-yo
tournament all the time it's gonna
happen I'm gonna be world champion don't
worry about it now yeah you're right
does he suck I think for me personally
if someone's vocal just go on a date or
whatever
explaining who you really are how you
feel it goes very far in a relationship
I would say was the time Christian like
you know excessive drink how the hell is
he still leaning like a little bit's
fine like if it's excess yeah a little
bit hard the smoking and drinking thing
you know I wouldn't want to date someone
who's there's a partier you know every
weekend that she's not really my scene
let's go T like I need someone who can
like twerk you know well at least he's
honest good luck finding a girl that's
what I want I want even if you can't do
it that well I want you to try like I'm
someone who can have fun I want to
continue from where we last ends up oh
god I want to continue from where we can
I do that accent is that okay for me to
do ah
what would you say is like a really big
town of yours I guess I can sing but
like I'm not very confident with it oh
cool I mean I'm not like horrible but I
haven't really been public about it I
guess um okay I don't know who she's
gonna eliminate Tyler he was talking
about twerking oh yeah of course
of course but he also didn't seem like
he was very serious about a relationship
and then I'm gonna have to uh Caleb no
particular reason just wasn't really
feeling it anymore I guess
damn that's me hair gel guys still in it
I kind of wanted to win at this point I
want to be able to say that I can own a
house but hopefully by the time I'm 30
you know have my family set how many
kids do you want
hopefully by like a boy and a girl to be
honest and then maybe like three or four
dogs so yeah with that oh yeah and I
want the boy to be a little older than
the girl see I want it the other way
around believe the boy oh my god for me
something that's really important I'm
trying to become a pilot and I've joined
the Navy to try and achieve that goal
and I'm still working there and that's
something I feel like for my partner I
want them to be the same mentality that
I'm in yeah too bad she's unemployed
okay if one person is motivated right
and the other person is doesn't really
care I've got a lot so I'm a musician
actor but I'm also studying political
science and I want to be President of
the night and you know being with
somebody that's like committed but also
like supportive and I can learn a lot
from them that that really means a lot
to me what about you I'm leaning towards
psychologists so I can help teens with
mental disorders and everything like
that there's a lot of I think genuine
connection and you really like care
about people you know because then you
can look beyond where they are and like
see them for who they truly can't be and
I think that's super special yeah okay
he's gonna win come on I'm cutting one
okay
hair gel guy come on don't let him down
I'm just gonna have to cut off Sam brah
look at this dude she could probably
smell the hair gel through the car and
she's like oh no I'm getting a bit
woodsy over here getting this isn't as
strong as the other two that I've been
getting no no all right final brand so I
want to know a little bit about you tell
me about yourself
what your Abhi's I like to dance wait
wait wait stop there stop there dance
are we talking like salsa or
breakdancing here cuz I'm okay with both
more so than anything okay that's cool
what else do you like so you like dance
you like to sing I was singing on my way
here that's cool what about photography
I'm kind of curious about that would you
like portraits landscapes um my main
focus I guess you could say is portrait
um I love shooting animals as well like
wildlife yeah you love taking a photo of
me then haha so what's the hardest thing
that you've ever been through and how
did you get through it and how did it
affect damn what a deep question one of
the hardest things I've had to go
through was probably middle school
beginning of high school because I
struggled with a lot of depression and
self-confidence
I've overcame it by like I'm starting to
love myself I'm super outgoing and I
help people so helping people yeah Danny
that's amazing
I would definitely say like you have to
embrace who you are because it's unique
and what you bring to the world is
different than any other person any
other individual all right okay yeah
yeah he's gonna work wait a minute
is he the guy that no is this the
episode is this the episode is happening
oh my god please I think I have a
decision do you guys know what's gonna
happen because I think I know Joseph
that last question that he asked me it
shows me that he can actually get really
deep when he needs to be
and that's the kind of stuff that I'm
looking for like I want someone who I
can have a ton of fun with but I can
also be super serious with yeah it looks
super serious that kind of set it over
the bar and that's what I'm looking for
oh my god oh oh look at him he's like oh
[ __ ] I'm definitely more used to like
talking to people like face-to-face and
being more real so solo we're in a
nutshell yeah this is all about yeah
that's what this is all about here it
comes
I'm good are you she's into him envision
you looking like anything but I'm really
happy you're cute thank you well I got a
girl oh god oh god that face - what
thank oh she was so in turn she opened
up for him about all these things and oh
I have this girl somewhere
I hope this oh you should have done it
in the in the impression that I did well
I got the girl looking forever
you're awesome though you're awesome
that you really call that I do I love
the only one that does though here where
are the people
really oh dang I told my girlfriend like
all about it everything
he's like yeah all right it's my turn
come on get out
did he think he automatically won
because they are the way what I thought
it was like a prank on me I was like
okay like no everyone else was like Oh
surprises me and I was like guess not oh
she she cried she crying for sure into
this thinking that I was gonna end up
with somebody who is single and like
looking but I mean I'm not hurt or
anything I'm just kind of confused as to
why you know her she hurt she crying
I mean it's whatever it's not whatever
it's not whatever shut the [ __ ] up ships
were looking for so I hope that they're
happy and everything actually I don't
care that was hilarious
what the hell what was he doing it would
be like a son what I wonder if he lied
after he saw her he's like oh yeah I got
a girl although to be fair he looks like
when he realized he's gets baked look at
his face when he realized he's like ah
SH that's what I'm looking for so okay I
think I think actually it was a lie
Joseph gets elected president of the
United States oh I actually I'm I'm
Prime Minister he knows she open up how
insecure she was to him and he really
went and did they damn we asked for
single people really really what what
it's a show by blind dates yeah come on
I can't believe I left that at me all
right
good meme good episode if you enjoyed
check out more as you believe videos on
their channel or mine I react to it epic
subscribe become member give access to
cool things thanks for supporting the
charity channel goes to charity and
that's it for now
Hado oh subscribe to beat Coco melon
children of nine parts it's time to race
what was once forgotten what creatures
far spells and pull troops awaits hope
tea is coming to Nintendo's way
and remember it has a very big TV
pre-order promotion timing
[Music]
jmes checkbook birthday girl ran away